on ne peut pas ne pas être touché par le
drame de la famille carrier mais les
événements suscitent quand même des
questions sur le mode de fonctionnement
des organismes qui envoie des
volontaires un peu partout dans le monde
est il temps de resserrer les règles du
jeu jacquin françois o day lé directeur
de l'observatoire canadien sur les
crises et l'aide humanitaire de l'uqam
en somme sur des bourgeois alors on
vient les voir les carriers il voulait
faire du bien il était là pour aider les
gens mais ils ce sont des bénévoles
humanitaires alors qu'elle leur rôle
qu'est ce qu'ils font exactement ce
bénévole avait coûté aux différentes
catégories de travailleurs
internationaux de coopération peut il
ces quatre là dépendre du type de
secteurs dans lesquels ils vont
travailler à donc le plus facile à
comprendre ce problème celui du secteur
de l'humanitaire à proprement parler
l'humanitaire on laisse aussi à
l'urgence ans donc on lan mais d'une
catastrophe naturelle ou d'un confit ou
dans des situations d'insécurité
justement comme le burkina est temps de
nous aurait été révélée cette semaine si
vous voulez et on a la dimension dans
les endroits plus stable où l'on parle
de coopération technique où on envoie
généralement des techniciens des
professionnels qui vont soutenir des
organisations locales
c'était le corps de ces gens là dans
cette organisation à la qui depuis
plusieurs années travaillent est
justement avec avec certains groupes
communautaires de la place le burkina a
changé l'afrique de l'ouest se changer
comme vous le savez les faits seulement
l'afrique de l'ouest
une grande partie du monde est en fait
une grande partie du monde l'afrique du
nord le moyen-orient mais l'afrique de
l'ouest particulièrement parce que des
pays comme le mali le burkina faso
n'était pas connue n'était pas de passer
nécessairement très violents étaient
même au contraire très stable c'est un
peu des oasis où la coopération était
facile et c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que
des organisations comme celle là et
d'autres ont sont multipliés parce que
les projets de coopération pour
justement des gens qui ont moins
d'expérience était possible mais est ce
que ces gens là on sont bien conscients
des risques et des dangers que
représente parfois le travail
humanitaire est ce qu'ils sont formés
pour aller dans ce genre de globalement
on peut dire qu'au canada les
organisations de coopération
ne sont pas suffisamment formés ou ont
pas suffisamment de capacités pour
encadrer les professionnels qu'ils
envoient à l'étranger je généralise
quand même beaucoup
il ya évidemment d'excellents
d'organisation qui font un travail très
professionnel qui anticipent les risques
et les diminue le risque zéro n'existant
pas commencé mais au moins on essaie d
anticiper on peut par exemple évacuer on
peut à la patrie cesser son personnel en
capital lors demandé de rester chez eux
et c'est qu'il est grand les
organisations même plus petit mais qui
ont ces protocoles ces pratiques de
sécurité là où ils sont habitués de
gérer dans des contexte d'insécurité
pour une organisation qui avait coutume
par exemple sur le long terme comme
c'est qu'au burkina ou mali d'être dans
un contexte relativement stable
évidemment depuis les deux trois
dernières années le contexte change et
l'influencent de des radicaux islamistes
s'est fait sentir même leur calme on
voit par exemple du personnel local qui
tout d'un coup de circuit la main aux
femmes n'adresse plus la parole à
certains à certains représentants parce
que justement ces représentants leçons
des occidentaux et les occidentaux
aujourd'hui dans ce secteur là
représentent ligne représente
envahisseurs alors clairement du jour au
lendemain ou en bonne quelques mots
quelques années des gens qui avaient le
dren accueil favorable sont aujourd'hui
identifiées vraiment pour par tout le
monde mais par les radicaux comme étant
évidemment des médias une menace
potentielle ou étant des envahisseurs
dans leur pays de leur maman
malheureusement le triste événement où
ils ont ils ont évidemment ciblé café un
hôtel qui était le lieu de rassemblement
traditionnel spécifiquement les
coopératives absolument pas mais
justement il ya certaines organisations
qui disait nous on avait prévenu nos
coopérants de ne pas aller dans les
endroits où fréquenté par les
occidentaux eux de toute évidence
n'avait pas eu cette consigne don kelly
a dit des consignes différentes selon
leur relation pour laquelle entre et je
vous dirai tristement que c'est quand
même le gros bon sens quand on travaille
à l'étranger dans un endroit où il ya un
risque effectivement d'attac
mais ni même aussi minime soit-il les
organisations qui vont justement
encadrer leurs professionnels vont leur
demander de ne pas fréquenter c'est lui
là c'est la première consigne de base
parce que lorsqu'il ya une attaque
évidemment c'est pas cependant le petit
boui boui dans un coin dans un coin de
rue du très éloigné du centre-ville mais
ça sera dans les hôtels qui représente
des symboles par exemple où justement
lorsque l'armée française fréquenter
régulièrement ou les conférences
rencontres les gens de la banque
mondiale vont se rencontrer
alors si c'est un lieu d'une
représentation qu'on va cibler bien sûr
ça a été une surprise pour tout le monde
cet attentat mais qu'est ce qu'il
faudrait leur donner de plus comme
formation pour aider puisqu'elle vous
dit s'il y en a de plus en plus de ces
gens qui vont dans les pays comme ça
deux choses je pense que d'une part les
organisations qui kiffent demande
veulent continuer dans ces secteurs le
doivent modifier leurs pratiques c'est
déjà une dame a engagé pour la plupart
d'entre elles celles qui sont
professionnels c'est à dire qu'ils ont
déjà anticipé ce risque à l'oeil qui
gèrent leurs professionnels adéquatement
il donc qu'ils doivent également
continuer à renforcer leurs capacités
puis là dessus le gouvernement canadien
leur province notamment doivent
supporter les organisations n'ont pas
beaucoup de ressources on sait donc ça
doit être supportée et l'autre chose
c'est des organisations qui ne sont pas
capables d'anticiper ces risques là
malheureusement doivent aller ailleurs
doivent aller dans un endroit dans un
pays où les risques sont beaucoup sont
réduits et où la menace terroriste
notamment est présente
alors s'il devrait y avoir évidemment
une transformation dans les opérations
et leurs pratiques sur la terre donc
resserrer les règles